네 이번에 bsn 빌딩 투자 스터디
33기를 모집을 합니다 저희 스터디는
2016년도에 처음 시작을 해서 8년
동안 이어온 강의입니다 정말 빌딩
투자의 도움이 될 만한 위주로 강의를
좀 준비를 했는데요 강의 내용은
1주차 때는 빌딩과 관련된 통계
자료라든지 앞으로 빌딩 투자를 어떻게
해야 되는지 내용을 중점적으로 좀
준비를 했습니다네 2주차 때는 빌딩
투자의 기본적인 내용 부터 좀
달았습니다 원율 용부터 좀 달았고
3주차 때는 저희 건축사 소장님과
시공사 대표님이 나오셔 가지고 강의를
진행할 예정이고 강의 시작하기 전에
저희가 설계와 시공했던 거를 현장
가서 소장님이 어떻게 설계를 했는지
설명을 해 드릴 예정입니다 4주차
때는 실제 매수자들이 필요한 세무
관련해서 강의를 진행할 예정입니다
5주차 때는 제가 나와서 성공
사례뿐만 아니라 실패 사례는 제가
유튜브에서 말씀을 못 드리거든요 근데
그런 실패 사례들 위주로 강의를
준비를 했고 빌딩 매입한 다음에 빌딩
관리가 되게 중요하거든요 관리를
어떻게 해야 되는지 내용을 가지고 좀
되게 알차게 준비를 했습니다
수강생분들의 혜택은 수강생분
네트워크분야 아니라 건축 관련해서
어디 물어볼 데가 없잖아요 그런 건축
상담이라는 그 시공사 대표님을 만날도
일이 없잖아요 근데 시공사 대표님
상담이라는 이런 것들이 다 무료로
진행되기 때문에 강의료가 전혀 아깝지
않은 빌딩 투자하는데 있어서 전문가
집단을 만들기 되게 어렵잖아요 그래서
그런 집단을 만들 수 있는 기회라고
생각합니다 저희한테 안 사셔도
되니까이 강의를 통해서 성공 사례들이
좀 많이 나왔으면 좋겠어요 진짜 어디
가서 사기를 안 당했으면 좋겠습니다
그리고 이상한 무슨 컨설팅 비용 이런
걸 내지 말고 저희 강의를 통해서
전문과 집단을 잘 이용하셨으면
좋겠습니다 정말 후회가 안 될 정도로
시간과 비용이 아깝지 않게 저희가
강의를 되게 알차게 준비했으니까 저를
믿고 신청을 하셨으면 좋겠습니다 그럼
저는 강의 때 인사드리도록 하겠습니다
n